all right guys I can't believe we were
lucky enough to get one of these
and the fact that it's turned up before
December
secret lair
30th Anniversary countdown kit
this arrived before the heads I win
tails you lose
commander deck turned up unbelievable
uh very excited to open up this we have
30 packs to open for Magics each of
Magic's 30 years that they've been
around
each of the packs has a 30 chance to
contain a foil version of some of the
cards uh so here's hoping
uh what do we want
Dragon guard l space
necropodance
those are some of the cards I want in
foil so without further ado
let's get into it
cheers to another 30 years
let's be honest you're going to open all
of these all at once
yeah we are
oh
and
bonus
D30 I think I've ever seen a D30 before
um so have the
ah it doesn't have
any symbols on it but okay D30
I'm sure that'll come useful in some DND
stuff
there's the Box
how will you hang your boosters fibofib
has some ideas
and there is a list of every set
that has come out from the beginning
all the way to jumpstart 22 so where did
I join in I joined in
right around here Shadow more Eventide
chart valara shots villaras when I was
playing competitively
okay cool
here we are
some little hangers which are never
going to see the light of day ever again
um
booster packs Galore
for every year are they in order are
they going to make my life easy okay
they are in order
foreign
let's do this
I've got my because I've heard these are
a pain in the ass to open so I've got
got some scissors with me
90 93
oh wow we
no he didn't
I thought we cracked our first foil
already but I want to open these without
damaging the card so
to start
gorgeous Shivan dragon
not foil
[Music]
the Tidy this area up
I'm gonna have a lot of cards on this
desk
94.
so what year
were you guys all playing I think you'd
do it all the way through there we go
what year did you all start playing
94 gets us
ual's Factory
which coincidentally goes with
oh
mishra's Foundry
good we haven't we haven't blown our
foil on any of the ones that I didn't
want so far it's literally the the years
I think 95 I think this is the
necropodance pack
this is one where we'd be happy with the
foil
oh
I think that's the way to do it
oh my God wait
that's the video guys we got the foil
necropones oh my word look at that ah
oh all right I'm stoked now so we should
be getting about 10 foils
on average and we got one of the best
ones oh beautiful okay that sits over
there I that's gorgeous I can't believe
how good that looks
uh what was 96
oh
break my lighting setup
[Music]
oh that's right Lim dolls vaults oh wow
is that foil as well oh my God it is
these are like the best ones wow I can't
believe how lucky we've gotten
Lim does vote in foil the art reminds me
of um Adventure Time
at 97
. you're gonna get real anxious about
accidentally
cutting through these
so for 97 we got
trade wind rider
okay okay
oh go on
so for our 98
we get
Smoke Stacks in the root
really weird like surreal artwork
I really like this card
I I am a Stax player I enjoy playing
stacks
so uh 1999 card
squeak Goblin Naboo in foil
again the artworks on all of these cards
are so good
to a thousand still I can't remember
when I first learned about magic
gathering when it was on my radar
I think it was
Maybe
even 2007 Maybe
oh so our 2000 card
I think it's blood buried no it's not
blood breed is it no it's not
it's Lynn civvy defiant hero I had never
heard of this card before I played a lot
of magic I've been playing since 2008.
I've never heard that card before
2001 so we're we're on the 2008 which I
think is
I think it's blood burrito
make sure
not to hit the card
so our 2001 card
wild Mongrel is that
is that in for that is in foil uh we've
got one of the Duds in foil
can't say I'll be playing wild Mongrel
in any format I mean the artwork's cool
not the
not the best foiling I think on this one
and you can already see we got the
the foil Bend
can't stand it up okay
all right that's all right we got about
six more foils to go
2002.
so uh 2002 card is
Genesis
so unfortunately they didn't put Wonder
or is it anger
would have been much more playable
I think we can still play that in
Commander 2003
so uh the 2003 card is
[Music]
Chrome holy crap how lucky are we Chrome
marks and we got the foil one
oh my word
that is gorgeous look at that
hope I cannot believe it
necropodence limbdul's Vault and now
Chrome marks what the hell
damn
2004. Chromebox was Meriden
so our 2004 card is
glimpse of nature I remember running
into this
when I played extended
pretty sure your hair was like extended
and running into elves
2005 is when I first moved to New
Zealand
all right and uh
2005 card is
Lightning Helix
lovely art on that
remember playing against lots of
Lightning Helix as well
for 2006
okay so our 2006 card is
Garden halkai this is another classic
Magic card
I'm again I remember playing uh against
this and extended
2007 so this is about the time where I
knew magic existed so I think my my
friends group
used to play and I remember saying I'm
never ever going to get into this game
here we are what 12 years later and I'm
super entrenched into this game
2007 or 2007 card is
Ponder this would have been a really
nice foil but I mean we're doing really
well on foils
again beautiful artwork
2008 I already noticed one blood braid
elf I played I never played blood breed
elf I was always the one trying to
counter blood breed elf
such an impactful card
now it's unfortunately fallen off the
power level power creep right
2008 bloodbreed elf oh and wait no
Heritage Droid whoops I think in 2009 is
blood burrito Heritage Druid there we go
another powerful card in the elf deck
2009 there we go hashtag spoilers this
this is blood burrito
uh 2009 card is
blood braid elf there she is and it's
the foil as well
very very nice again such a powerful
card but such a shame that it it's full
enough
move these across slightly
did I I think I can't remember if I went
to Nationals this year
let's have a look
so our 2010 card is
Sun Titan and a foil or
remember the Titan cycle Sun Titan Frost
Titan
primeval Titan
and then the red one I forgot Mountain
Titan I've forgotten
oh
all right it foil's uh catching out how
many floors are we in one two three four
five six seven potentially three more
foils to go
on average we might get lucky and get
more 2011.
uh
2011 card is
birthing pot oh my God this we got a
birthing pod in foil this is such an
amazing artwork
and we got it in foil holy crap
oh
that's my old friend used to say I get
so lucky I cannot believe
2012.
so is this this is after the fraxian set
so
key one here in this rod
so uh 2012 card is
death right oh you have got to be
kidding me this is in foil as well
oh wow
Mark Riddick this is like the
necropotence art or very similar
holy wow
Sun Titan deathrite shaman
I mean you can't really ask for a better
30th Anniversary box somewhere surely
okay so our 2013 card is
ellsworth's son's Champion I was not
playing standard during this time but I
heard how awesome this card was this is
the one that we did want in foil
unfortunately did not get it but still
cool nonetheless
2014 just to make sure
I'm not gonna cut into these
so we've got the I think this is
nicobola is the last card that I want
now in foil so of 2014 our card is
Siege rhino
I remember how miserable it was I heard
how miserable it was playing against
this card again love the art on this
2015.
our 2015 card
is
dragon lord ugita
wow
are we at our foil cap did we hit our
foil cap
let's see
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten okay we could we may have hit
our foil cap
let's see we've still got a couple more
to go
remember they said it's a 30 chance
2016.
foreign
2016 card is
Thalia heretic kathar and we got it in
foil we've broken the 30 barrier
awesome awesome card
2017.
so when was Rosalia the return to in
Australia set
so are we at Allen kit now
2017.
[Music]
a 2017 card is
nicobolus godfaro uh unfortunately not
in foil but I mean we've gotten pretty
lucky so can't complain love a little
chubby artwork here
foreign
[Music]
2018's card is
Arc like Phoenix
I remember playing against this just all
through uh his start basically on a
magic Arena online historic and standard
great contamflow 2019 almost there
it's when I was working at the card shop
and got back into magic for a little bit
again
so 2019 our card is
Emery lurker of the lock turns out drain
I want to throwback there's another one
I wanted in foil but again
can't complain
three more
20 20. is this spellbinder mage
our card for 2020 is
shark typhoon oh this is the other one I
wanted in foil I love the artwork on
this card
like uh what is it Sharknado
shock typhoon
all right 2021
okay this is spellbinder mage
so I card for 2021 is
Elite spellbinder Mage in foil or this
reminds me of old like Classic X-Men oh
no watch man Dr Manhattan
awesome awesome add that to the foils
alrighty
last pack 2022 for Magic's 30th
anniversary
let's do this
and
spoilers there are two cards
so for Magic
2022 pack we've got card number one
gnashi
Moon Sage Scion
and the final card is
LOL my God foil Lotus field are you
kidding me holy crap
well
what a box to open let's quickly go over
the foils
once more let's quickly scoop these up I
can't believe how lucky we got with this
set
so we got Lotus field
Dragon Lord
uchita I love the foiling across the top
here
spellbinder mage
Thalia heretic Qatar
deathrite shaman
birthing pod
Sun Titan
blood braid elf
Crow marks
wild mongrel
squee
limdor's Vault and
I think my personal favorite
necropodance holy crap well
let me know in the comments down below
if you guys did manage to score
30th Anniversary I got very lucky I was
up at 3am trying to order it had my
orders canceled and it was a bit of a
nightmare
but very pleased with that uh yeah
stand by for hentai win Tales you lose
which hopefully is coming soon I mean
it's been over a year now uh check out
our other Commander content thank you so
much for stopping by
and I'll see you guys next time